I mean, this is a tough opponent
all year.
You know, we're playing a team
that's
very talented. Make it this
point for a reason and we had
to everything. We do to get the
win.
This is a football team that's
been playing really well. Good
on offense. I got a very good
defense. Good front then very
healthy.
It's going to be a very tough
tough game.
Yeah, I mean you're going to
hear that from Tom Brady.
Almost no matter what right?
That's that's how he does
business is going to build up
the opponent and turn that I'm
sure he probably feels pretty
good about this matchup, but
it's not the same All-Star
team that the Tom Brady, sort of
as
GM and cornerback had built.
There's no Antonio Brown.
There's no Chris Godwin is going
to be some new looking
weapons. If they're going to go
do this thing. How do you feel
right now? What's your
temperature
on the Tampa Bay Buccaneers
heading into the playoffs?
I feel good. I got Tom Brady, if
I'm not a baby, I feel good.
I still have Tom Brady, I think
about it. It wasn't like Tom.
Brady was throwing to
All Pro and Hall of Fame
receivers when he was winning
championships in 2001. 2003 2004
back-to-back
championships. It wasn't like he
was throwing to Hall of
Famers and
you know, guys like that. He was
throwing to David Givens,
Deion Branch David Patten and
those type of guys and Daniel
Graham was our tight end. These
guys aren't going to be in
a Hall of Fame there. Really?
The football players, they
unselfish, they do everything
they can for the team. So Tom is
going to be very comfortable
with those other guys here.
They're going to be a level of
frustration at times. But the
most important thing Tampa has
to do is not get
dominated. Like, they got
dominated on the line of
scrimmage, against the New
Orleans Saints and
the Philadelphia Eagles. They
have those pass rushers their
deep.
They can rotate guys from the
inside from the outside. So
that's going to be the tell of
the game can Philadelphia
put pressure on. Tom, Brady and
hit.
Him and get him off his Mark and
make him uncomfortable
Jack.
It's a good point. We've seen
that Eagles front, give him
issues in the past, man is still
a Super Bowl from him.
What that exact formula. Yeah.
That's why I don't know if it's
quite to that level,
but they still got a whole bunch
of those players right
here. Scotty Miller. That's the
same player is, that's one of
those young receivers. One of
those lesser known receivers
referred to remember against the
Packers in the NFC
championship game. He caught
that touchdown right before
halftime.
Very reason why they go on to
win this game. And you know,
I think Tom has enough time
here, you know, losing a be was
losing. When there's been enough
time for him to realize,
I need to start ripping out with
these young guys of these
inexperience guys, and
once he gets those reps,
that's when it usually starts to
happen. Let's hear from
Bruce Arians. Here's head coach
on talking his quarterback
potential MVP chances. Here's
what he had to say.
Bruce
make this a sink case for your
quarterback as
as the MVP of this league this
season.
Other you've if he doesn't get
it, it's a travesty.
I mean
most completions ever. 5,000
yards, two touchdowns,
the whole, the whole nine yards.
I mean,
I mean to me, it's not even,
it's not even a close race.
Ha ha ha, a little bias this
right now,
but I'm gonna tell you this.
Yeah, Tom Brady was fantastic
and that's my dude, right?
That's my dude. And he played
unbelievable this year, but
nobody played better than Aaron
Rodgers. I got a, we got a
chance to be up close and
personal
and watch Aaron Rodgers and that
magic and all
the different injuries. On the
offensive line him playing with
a hurt, big toe, and nobody was
better than Aaron Rodgers. Flat
out. Aaron Rodgers was the man.
I don't care about records.
I don't care about numbers
completions at the end of the
day.
When I saw Aaron Rodgers play, I
said, this is the best. This
is the best player in the
National Football League.
Nobody can do the things that he
does the way he does it. And
Tom Brady is my dude. He's in a
close second. But Aaron Rodgers
should be the most valuable
player in this league.
Yeah. I don't think there's any
question. I am all over
the air. Ride was trained on
this one. I mean, he threw
those,
you look at his stats, man. He
has, you know, 400 seconds to
of those cave that first week in
the season. When he's still
coming back from Hawaii mode in
vacation mode and he really
liked you basically skip the
preseason. It just goes out
there and chokes the Saints. A
couple picks a week. One like
the rest of the year. He was
damn near perfect, man. I mean,
this was
this, this season for Mary
Rogers. I have no doubt that
he's the MVP as well. Let's get
you to this next matchup for
Wildcard Weekend, San Francisco.
Niners,
they're headed into Dallas.
First thought that comes to
mind when you think about that
game.
San Francisco. You said? Yeah,
it's an France against Dallas.
Once again, it goes back to
Jimmy G. I think it goes back
to Jimmy G. He's going to have
to deal with this pass rush.
I know Cal Shanahan,
he's going to do all that run
and all that motion and
all the misdirection and things
like that.
But at the end of the day, man
when the Cowboys when they're
focused when they're healthy,
when they're honed in and
they're focused on football and
not all the other crap that's
going on. This is a very very
good football team. We're going
to see exactly if Mike McCarthy.
Can have his team
ready? This is the one of the
most talented teams that I've
ever seen
from the Dallas Cowboys both on
offense and defense,
you got the quarterback you
want? I Ron Smith. He's going
to be back 111, change, man.
When I watch Zeke, Zeke has out
average.
He's just an average running
back, man. He looks slow.
What I think it was last week
when they started putting those
other running backs in, you can
just see the difference in
speed is the difference in
quickness. The different and
explosive plays.
Zeke is not that guy. You need
to put
Put Tony Pollard give him more
opportunities
to carry that that the ball on
an offensive side of the ball,
and I just I don't like what I
see from Zee.
Yeah, he still gets those Ace
responsibilities as the number
one back, probably more. So,
based on his resume, his career
resume, then based on what's
happened this season, because
when Tony Pollard carries the
football, he is so much faster
and more explosive runs harder
and Zeke looks like he's got a
knee injury. That's honestly
what it looks like to me. I like
the Cowboys in that game
though. I really do. I think
that Cowboys defense overwhelms
in a lot of ways what Jimmy
Garoppolo is trying to do
throwing the ball. We've seen
those those three pass rushers
with
Lawrence. Randy Gregory. Michael
Parsons,
that's As good of a trios you're
going to find. I think
that's a Cowboys win. I'm more
nervous about the Cowboys
playing a team like the
Cardinals, but that maybe down
the line. Let's get to Arizona,
Arizona.
They're going to have to play
the Rams. So these are two
teams here. Arizona has one in
Allah. As one in Arizona, round
three upcoming. How do you see
it?
Wow, I'm Kyle Amory is, he's
incredible. It really hasn't
been the same. Since DeAndre
Hopkins is gone. It's, he's
still trying to get a feel.
But to me, I like Arizona's
defense. I think they have
a bunch of really good athletes.
They get, guys, they can get
after you. And I like Vance,
Joseph aggressive approach.
He's going to Blitz. He's gonna,
you know, he's gonna and, you
know, he's going to get after
Matthew Stafford. And that's
what you have to do. You have
to pressure Matthew Stafford,
you know,
of course Cooper cup double team
him and a particular
situation. And see if Odell
Beckham see if those other guys
can really step up and make the
plays. But if I'm Arizona, I'm
Vance Joseph. There's no way I'm
allowing Cooper cup to
destroy me this game. He's not
catching tip 10 or 12 passes
for 150 yards. That's not going
to be the case. I'm
double-teaming him.
I'm taking him out the game.
It's a damn hard matchup, man.
That's a damn hard Macho. If
you're shy McVeigh and year one
where you master playing this
whole thing to bring Stafford in
and there's so much Super
Bowl expectation right now and
it's almost Super Bowl or bust
with the way that they put this
team together
and to have to go play the
Cardinals,
their bring it back, JJ Watt.
They have been undefeated this
year undefeated with j.j. Watt,
God defense already talented,
without him. But if he comes
back and can just give them
something that's going to be a
scary sight.